[Music]
okay I guess we'll probably kick off
just like I say thanks very much to the
organizers of Pi data for giving me the
opportunity to speak today I'm going to
be speaking about recent attempts to
marry Bayesian methods with deep
learning I'm going to be introducing a
new probabilistic programming framework
called Edwards to do that which was spun
out of David Bligh's lab at Columbia I'm
going to look at recent development
which shows that drop/add in neural
networks which I'll explain is in fact a
form of approximate inference and then
I'm going to actually compare
experiments carried out using the
blackbox variational inference in Edward
with drop/add I actually have no idea
what the results would be when I
submitted the proposal to this talk so
it's quite addressing for me to I'm
going to assume for the purposes of this
talk that most people have some idea
what a neural network is so a neural
network is a nonlinear function
approximator we can think of the neural
network as a parameterised function
where the parameters are the weights and
biases of the neural network typically
we will be passing our data to some kind
of non-linearity like a sigmoid or
rectified linear unit and often we can
compose these nonlinear functions
together hence deep learning deep neural
networks with with multiple layers of
these function compositions so I'm sure
you don't need me to tell you that
there's been lots of state-of-the-art
developments for for deep neural
networks in all manner of data fields
you know quite famously we've also seen
deep neural networks underpinning some
work in deep Q learning which you sought
to use to kind of play Atari 2600 or to
play go deep neural networks are
difficult to train but there has been
lots of algorithmic innovations things
like stochastic optimization things like
drop Ives to regularize networks which
has made your training on very very
large datasets possible of course things
like beyond oh and tensor flow as well
do not sort of automatic difference
okay so what are the drawbacks of
standard deep learning and by standard
here I mean non-bayesian well in the
first instance neural networks compute
point estimates of their weights and
therefore they compute point they make
point predictions as well they can
therefore make very overly confident
predictions about the particular class
of an object even if this is some sample
that has been very far from the training
data that they've already seen so they
can you know very standard very
confidently predict in a very wrong kind
of way they have lots of parameters so
you're kind of working industrial deep
neural network and have millions of
parameters and this gives ample scope to
to overfit so therefore you tend to need
very large datasets to try and offset
this they also have lots of parameters
that need to be said things like dropout
probability you know things like
learning rate etc and all these things
make life difficult so the aim of
probabilistic machine learning in
general is to try and represent our
uncertainty about predictions or about
the models that we're using so you know
why would this be potentially
significant I mean if you're trying to
classify several million images and your
neural network misclassifies a few
images of the caste as being a dog it's
probably not the end of the world
however if you have an application where
you have some important decision which
needs to be made on the basis partially
of a prediction of a neural network you
would like to know how uncertain your
network is about its predictions and you
can think of obvious applications and
things like a physician making a
diagnosis in medicine or potentially in
finance where you could have a trading
model which is giving you a trading
signal you know buy this asset okay
you'll say well how much capital shall I
commit how confident is this trading
model in this buy signal so you'd like
to actually have some sort of
uncertainty bounds let's say around your
estimate and this is really at the core
of attempts to try to marry these
Bayesian approaches with with deep
learning so what is a Bayesian neural
network a Bayesian neural network is a
neural network with prior distributions
on the weight
so this accounts for uncertainty in the
way you could think of your choice of
Pryor as being like the range of the
weights that you are willing to accept
your network to have once you have this
view of uncertainty about your weights
you can then propagate this into having
a view on the uncertainty of your
predictions this also makes things very
robust against overfitting which is
generally a kind of feature of bayesian
methods and you know in some instances
you can kind of infer hyper parameters
by marking them out I'm not going to say
too much about that in the case of a Bay
the neural network you have input data X
you try to make some prediction on on
I'd put data Y your parameters are the
network weights and biases now typically
for Bayesian neural networks in practice
people tend to put normal distributions
over the weights to reflect their
uncertainty essentially in the value of
those weights
okay so trying to keep the equations to
a relative minimum but let's consider
the general inference problem you have
some observed data you have some latent
variable whose value you are trying to
infer now in the case of a Bayesian
neural network your latent variable will
be the weights of the network and this
is of course the famous Bayes rule at
the top I'm trying to update my prior
belief about the weights in light of
data that I've subsequently observed so
I'm interested in the posterior
distribution of my weights given the
data that I've observed now the second
equation here is really where the kind
of magic happens as far as Bayesian
methods go let's say I show my train
network a new data point X and I want to
make a prediction Y star what I'm
essentially doing here is getting a
distribution over my prediction I'm
sampling my posterior
lots of times randomly so if you think
about what you're doing here you're
actually kind of summing over lots of
neural networks with slightly different
weights because you're sampling your
weights from your posterior so in that
sense you can kind of think of Bayesian
prediction as
being a form of ensemble example taken
from the simple Bayesian neural network
example on the adword website so there's
a simple cosine function here with a
little bit of noise you're trying to fit
it with a Bayesian neural network these
are all neural network models with
slightly different weights and you can
see you're kind of getting a some
measure of the kind of uncertainty in
your model while trying to make this
prediction okay but that's all well and
good but as we know this kind of stuff
is quite difficult exact inference is
generally intractable so you need to
approximate this posterior so this is
all this what we're trying to do in
Bayesian inference we want to
approximate the posterior of the latent
variable we're trying to infer in this
case this will be the weights of the
neural network so in fact the subject
has a very very long history you know
you can look back to the brilliant work
of David Mackay in the early 90s he
published four papers on bays in neural
networks which made up his PhD thesis
the first attempt to do basically
variation variational inference was by
Hinton and on camp in 1993 we've had
groundbreaking work by Radford Neil and
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo and for people
interested in this there's actually a
really great keynote address by Zubin
guru Monty at this year's nibs
conference where he gives a very
accessible account of the history of
this subject ok so what happened here
well these methods were generally not
scalable to master data sets and for
actually a good decade and a half the
field went into some degree of dormancy
until relatively recently so for example
there's been revival based in deep
learning this was the subject of one of
the biggest workshops nips in December
in Barcelona you can get some of the
talks here some of it kicked off with
this top paper by Alex graves where he
came up with a practical Monte Carlo
estimator for doing variational
inference in neural networks and again
there's a very good account given in
yarn girls PhD thesis which was
submitted towards the back end of last
year kind of traces the subject and
discusses all these papers in more death
okay so moving on to probabilistic
programming with
édouard so generally probabilistic
programming tries to represent
probabilistic models so probability
distributions of programs that generate
samples so in principle any computer
program with a random number generator
can be a probabilistic program the
general idea is we're trying to infer
some unobserved variables in the model
conditioned on the program output so
you're running the program lots of times
you're getting slightly different random
outputs and you're looking at those
outputs and you're trying to infer some
observed variable in the model they say
we've got lots of different
probabilistic programming languages the
first five here I think it's probably
fair to say are more in the research
language domain church and venture you
know they're kind of probabilistic lists
that came out of MIT to allow three Stan
PI MC three Edwards I think these are
programs are probabilistic programming
frameworks which are probably more
useful maybe to practitioners to applied
scientists on data scientists now one
feature of a lot of these languages is
they try to put the inference engine
quite separately to the model now the
idea behind this is that a working
programmer who is not necessarily an
expert in Bayesian inference can just
specify a model and then just pass the
model into this inference black box that
would just do the inference the user
doesn't have to be an expert the user
doesn't have to do a very model specific
type of inference that's that's all well
and good as a design principle but in
fact for some recent developments in in
things like generative adversarial
networks in deep learning it actually
creates a bit of a problem because the
the models representation is actually
reused in the inference process so that
could create a problem for maybe some of
these languages like like church
adventure but not so Edward so generally
these languages will suffer from this
kind of expressivity versus scalability
trade-off you have something like Church
venture it's very very expressive but
you know you're not going to be able to
scale it up to very large data and this
is actually a quote which came up in my
Twitter feed which I quite liked by
Daniel Roy who's one of the developers
of the church
I think the context was a discussion
about adding closures to Stan is that
all to visually complex TPR is
essentially implement probabilistic
lists so on to Edward Edward is a thin
platform over tensorflow
so Edward basically is tensorflow plus
the addition of random variable classes
plus the addition of inference algorithm
so it looks and feels like tensorflow as
you're using it so what is tensorflow we
probably had a very good discussion of
it so I'm not going to spend too much
time tensorflow with the computational
graph framework so if you think of
something like numpy you might be doing
a series of calculations you're moving
data to the Seebeck end and then you're
pulling it back into Python and you're
moving it back again there's a
communication overhead involved in all
those transformations in the case of
chancer flow you just build this large
graph of the computations you're going
to do in advance lazily and only at the
very end do you feed it with some data
tensorflow
is obviously quite geared towards a deep
learning community it's got a lot of
functionality in that direction but it
does not by any means need to be used to
do deeper learning at all you also have
access to a lot of scalability
distribution you have all these
excellent stochastic optimizers etc so
Edwards basically adds these random
variables as class objects they have
things like log probability sampling
summary statistics so how do you
actually get around them variable into
the tensor flow framework well if you
consider a tensor in tensor flow you're
just wrapping it with this kind of
object you're considering the tensor
flow tensor to be sample from some
random variable object so it's a
relatively simple idea but it's actually
kind of guess the probabilistic
programming aspect is the tensor flow
quite well now this is how you can
define probabilistic models so Edward
has a lot of different inference
algorithms and you know under the hood
they can all leverage tensor flows
excellent inbuilt optimizes gradient
gradient descent mechanisms so Edwards
therefore kind of allows this
composition of models which is a very
common thing in
you know probabilistic graphical models
for example but you can also compile
inference methods together which makes
it very very flexible so an example of
why you would want to do this would
maybe be something like expectation
maximization algorithm where you could
have two different inference engines
running simultaneously very importantly
of course we allow data subsampling so
we can do mini batching we can do
sarcastic optimization and that allows
you to scale this up to two very big
sizes in terms of data set so AdWords
general philosophy this is where the
name Edward actually comes from the
statistician George Edward Pelham box so
the idea here is you know you specify a
model then you do some inference on the
model but you know what if your model is
misspecified
well you'd like to be able to go back
and do some predictive checks after
you've done your inference whether you
can reproduce features of the data this
is very integral to the the general
design framework of of Adwords and it's
describing these two papers here Justin
Tron is is the lead developer he's a
graduate student of David glides out at
Columbia okay so what does editor
actually look like well this is a two
layer neural network in tensorflow I'm
using touch activation functions here
now in the case of Edwards we're doing
probabilistic programming we'd like to
have priors over our weights and this is
basically how you add them so it's it's
looking quite quite tensorflow like
overall ok just very quickly I mean
again the general inference problem you
have some observed data you have some
latent variables that you're trying to
infer and then you have some posterior
approximation to those variables in
adverts you're just going to find your
your weight to your posterior is denoted
by qw to the weight QB for the bias
similarly for your data and then this is
the sort of very simple interface you
will use to actually do the inference
you have your latent variables that
you're trying to infer you have your
data and then you select
inference algorithm which is built into
AdWords so they all inherit from this
inference class it can be variational
inference Monte Carlo it's got a lot of
things a lot of things in there this
abstraction can represent a very broad
class of models so I think the sort of
interface in in Edward is quite Terrace
it kind of works by well in that respect
okay so the thing I'll be looking at in
particular will be variational inference
again if you think of variational
inference you're trying to approximate
the weight posterior variational
inference works by positing some
approximate Osteria parameterised by
some parameters theta you're trying to
make this approximate posterior as close
to the actual posterior as possible
you're trying to minimize the divergence
between the two by sort of turning the
little dial of your parameters until you
pull the approximate posterior as close
to your posterior as possible
typically for reasons of computational
tractability a mean field approximation
is often used what that means
essentially is each of your weight
layers are considered to be independent
of each other
and they don't interact I think that
this might actually cause problems later
on down the line some of the very high
dimensional neural networks but I'll
show you those examples later
unfortunately minimizing this divergence
between your approximate posterior and
the actual posterior is hard because you
have this evidence term which is one of
the reasons you're doing approximate
Bayesian inference in the first place
fortunately with a very minor bit of
equation shuffling you can come up with
this other quantity the evidence lower
band minimizing the divergence between
your approximate posterior and the
actual posterior is the same as
maximizing this other quantity called
the evidence lower band the evidence
lower band consists of these two terms
the first one tries to make sure that
your approximate weight posterior is
giving you good samples that look like
they explain the data quite well and the
second term is ensuring that your
approximate posterior is not going off
doing its own thing too much that it's
close enough to your priors so this is
like a term that penalizes excessive
complexity
it's like a nocturnes razor term you
could call it okay to optimize the other
we want to maximize it so we need its
gradient one of the innovations of the
so called black box variational
inference is that you can estimate this
gradient using Monte Carlo sampling so
you don't need to actually have any real
knowledge of the models that you're
using this is a very generic type of
approach that will work for the elbows
of any model pretty much it's a black
box approach it makes it very very
scalable one of the problems of course
is any Monte Carlo estimation is that
the gradient estimation can be quite
noisy so what Edward does is you you
showed a model it automatically selects
from a lot of black box inference
techniques so you just decide I want to
do k l QP is the name of the class and
then you don't really need to worry
about it because Edward will try to to
optimize this as best it can using these
black box variational inference
techniques
okay so changing tack a little bit we go
back to the idea of deep neural networks
in particular now one of the big
developments in neural networks was in
2014 this papers through the stava
internet al where they find a way of
regularizing neural networks using
dropouts so literally what they're doing
is they're taking the weight matrix of a
neural network they're multiplying it by
some binary vector of ones and zeros
where the probability that an entry is
one is given by a Bernoulli distribution
parameter P and where the binary vector
value is zero you're basically just
switching off or dropping out the hidden
unit in a particular layer so during the
training you're doing this lots of times
so what actually what you're doing is
you're showing that you're getting
you're passing the data through a
slightly different network every time
and this prevents the network from Co
adapting too much to your particular
data set so it greatly improves
out-of-sample performance and it's
generally been a very very very big
development that's allowed your training
and much larger neural networks and data
sets
okay so well has that related to
variational inference well I mean if you
think back to my earlier point about the
predictive distribution they're kind of
randomly sampling from a posterior
overweight so you're kind of averaging
over slightly different neural network
models with slightly different weights
that sounds a little bit like what
you're doing with drop it let's say you
have a loss function this is for a
neural network your loss function could
be mean squared error in the case of a
regression problem you have some
regularization and you're assuming that
your network has been trained with this
drawford capability what Yaron gal who's
a was at the time a graduate student of
Zubin jaramana a Cambridge Sheldon 2015
was that you could reap remoter eyes
this variational distribution this elbow
thing and that you could actually make
it look a lot more like a dropout
objective I mean essentially to not go
into the detail orbit they show that
your variational inference objective and
a drop at neural network objective are
in fact the same formally now the proof
of this somewhat involved and it calls
upon the theory of Gaussian processes so
I'll just say this about it a Gaussian
process as shown by result of Radford
Neil in the early 90s essentially a
neural network with a single layer
that's infinitely wide with Gaussian
priors in all the ways is a Gaussian
process and that was basically the sort
of the undertone to this kind of work so
we don't need to talk too much about
that because I want to get on and show
the results essentially optimizing any
neural network with dropout is
equivalent to a form of approximate
Bayesian inference by this repr
amortization of Garland Guerra mani a
network trained with dropout just a
standard network that maybe some of you
have used already is a Bayesian network
okay so that's all been a lot of theory
but how do you actually implement this
dropout as Bayesian approximation in
practice well essentially what you do is
you're applying the drop out layer a
test time so you're taking your test
data you're running it through your
trained neural network you're applying
these rapid filters at test time now
that's not typically how job ID has been
applied in the past
generally drop out was quite an ad-hoc
empirical technique and practitioners
tended to tended to apply a training
time an hour test time they would just
use a sort of weight averaging so here
again is our old friend the predictive
distribution again we are taking our
tests at X we're firing it through the
neural network to get an output Y and
we're getting a different way every time
because we're applying a drop a
different drop by filter so actually if
you keep doing this lots of times you do
T stochastic forward passes through the
network and you start to actually get
this distribution of predictions Y now
that distribution effectively is the
Bayesian predictive distribution that we
saw at the start of the talk so if you
want to estimate rather than get a point
estimate from your neural network you
can now get a predictive mean and a
variance around that by simply
collecting the results of these
stochastic forward passes through an
existing neural network trained to drop
out so clearly if your model is more
uncertain or you have a lot of
predictive uncertainty your neural
network predictive distribution will be
wider okay so I just like to say that
this has also been very successfully
applied in a range of different
architectures to get state-of-the-art
results for example on C far 10 and
convolutional neural networks
similarly getting very impressive
results for recurrent neural networks on
the penn treebank data set and also in
reinforcement learning okay so what I
wanted to do was compare essentially the
same basal neural network trained using
blackbox variational inference in
Edwards with one trained using this MC
Drophead which is the generic term that
that they use I looked at a feed-forward
neural network with two hidden layers
and 50 units per layer now the reason I
did this was because this was fought was
used in these two publications the first
one was by her
as Lobato and Ryan Adams they used an
inference method called expectation
propagation and the second is the
original MC draw fed paper by garland
Guerra mani so they used that 10 public
publicly available benchmark data sets
you can use the code this is what I used
to use MC drop/add after a pull request
it's actually possible to do this in
chaos so you can actually run MC drop
that straight away in chaos
this code was based on earlier code by
Hernandez Lovato and Adams okay so here
are my results so again I had no idea
what we come out of this when I
submitted the proposal to PI data but we
have a series of data sets on the side
for example Boston Housing tries to
explain the price of Boston housing
against 12 or their explanatory
variables some of them are categorical
some of them are continuous so what we
have here is the root mean squared error
so we all want this obviously to be low
low is good
for standard drawback which is how
practitioners how to fly dropout before
you train your network of dropout and
then at test time you do a single pass
through with all the weights average you
see some of these these results MC
dropout which is where you are test time
multiple you run your test step through
the network many times with tropics
which John does better in every single
case sometimes substantially better now
BBV is what I call black box variational
inference which is what's currently
implemented in AdWords for a units 54 a
Network 50 units wide it's actually not
terribly good what I did find it was
interesting is when I dropped the width
of the network from 50 to 10 therefore
making it a lower dimensional problem I
got some improvement and at least in the
case of the yacht hydrodynamics data set
you're seeing improvements which are you
seeing results would seem to improve
over standard drop it at least I should
add that these are very small data sets
ideally you should be probably shuffling
making lots and lots of splits and
running this several times and averaging
over the results so these estimates are
going to be very noisy I would take this
to be a very much ballpark kind of
comparative indicator so there could be
quite if you run this again I'm saying
you could get these numbers jumping
around quite a bit so that's probably
good practice to do this at the bottom
the test log likelihood it's just a
measure of how well our model fits the
data so you want these numbers to be
less negative less negative is good and
again you see the results here MC
dropout is generally looking pretty good
black box variation inference with ten
units doesn't look too bad either no so
so what's going on here in the first
instance we should admit the primary
possibility that I've done something
wrong in the modeling if you know if
that's not the case then we should think
about the kind of approximation that
black box variation inference is using
anybody was that Patrick oil's talk
yesterday that they'll see of Jameis Lee
plagiarized this chart from his
excellent repo and advanced PI MC 3 so I
think she'd definitely check that out
but yeah Edward is using mean field
variation inference so the assumption is
actually that all the weight layers are
completely separate they're not
correlated there's no interaction
between them I've seen a good
description in a paper by Lewis and
Welling where they say if you're doing a
mean field approximation you're
essentially you have a unimodal bump in
the very high dimensional parameter
space of the neural network but you know
maybe the real posterior is quite
multimodal you might have lots of peaks
and maybe the mean field distribution
particularly at high high dimensions is
just simply not flexible enough to
capture the real posterior this is my
own summation on the other hand MC
dropout though this is very far from
obvious it actually gives you a
posterior which is multimodal so it may
be that MC dropout it just managing to
capture the real approximate posterior
the real posterior a little bit better
since submitting this I also came across
a paper by Luther swelling where they
actually run
another form of Bayesian neural networks
on the same data sets that I just helped
there where they try to include some
sort of correlation between the weight
layers and their results most of the
time are actually better even than MC
drawbacks so it again lends credence
perhaps to the idea that you need to
include some correlations and they
become increasingly important as you
increase the dimensionality of your deep
neural network so I use two hidden
layers that's probably the minimum that
you could possibly call deep neural
network but again like my motivation was
in following the papers that I quoted so
you know this could be the next research
direction really for variational
inference there's a lot of work going on
in making better and more flexible
posterior approximations that go beyond
the mean field approximation normalizing
flows if you heard recall yesterday that
currently being worked on to go into PI
and c3 and another very active area
researches in making these monte carlo
estimators of the elbow less noisy but i
just like to say this work was done by
me as a swung project in the personal
capacity but i work out a brokerage
called prism FP we have offices in
London and New York we are in the
process of spinning out a new shin tech
company prism FP analytics which is
going to be doing sort of
next-generation analytics for the asset
management industry and I'm looking at
some interesting research there
including some Bayesian models it's so
stealth mode that we don't have a
website just yet but by all means if
you're interested please grab me any
point today to just go further
thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah yeah yes yeah yes I would expect me
to say you know maybe you're missin a
lot but in the areas where it had strong
confidence or is also really good but it
but in the areas where it had low
confidence maybe they weren't as good
did I misunderstand or no I think
probably it's definitely a
presentational issue in my part I should
have been included in an example perhaps
that has a lower dimension that can be
plotted quite easily you know I could
look at a one-dimensional function and
plot the uncertainty bands around it
these problems are all quite high
dimensional so it's quite difficult to
to represent the the uncertainty
estimate quite clearly you know if you
look at the original paper by garland
guerre Amani it gives you a good kind of
idea in the context of say the amnesty
data set they take the digit 1 it's
classified with a very high degree of
confidence they then start to spin the
one around and you can see the model
uncertainty estimates expanding as it
moves towards the digit which the two
trainings which the model hasn't seen
before and it starts to miss classified
as a three but the confidence intervals
are very wide so yeah if I'd a bit more
time I would definitely like to have
included something along those lines in
the first example was the Boston housing
data right I'll be predicting a single
price for each input they're so good
yeah you have a you are I mean there are
you can't get confidence bands around
those as well
I just didn't include them essentially
other partially because they're not
included in the original data set it was
just trying to show I think that I guess
V the the anti overfitting capability of
the basic invasion Ural network is very
useful so I have kind of tracked that
paper as closely as possible
but definitely something I would like to
look at more I should also say again I
emphasize that they run this 20 times
and got a big standard error over that
which which I didn't include quick
question over here
hi thank you so much again for a very
interesting talk I really liked the idea
of the emcee drop out would you mind
explaining how the parameters of the
Bernoulli distribution were estimated
and how robust your inferences - yeah I
mean they they didn't try to do any
fancy estimation of the P the estimation
of a unit being dropped out they used P
of about 5% now there is another paper
by Kingma and Welling where they try to
actually do a sort of Bayesian
marginalization of that P probability
called variational drop at where they
try to estimate that using a Bayesian
inference as well but as far as I know
this paper they did actually find also
that the results were quite sensitive to
your choice of P so for for some cases
moving from a P of 1% to 5% is actually
have quite big impact on the the
accuracy of the rmse afterwards
no I took the values straight out of
these papers and these papers didn't
specify exactly how they came across the
P there is another parameter they use
the Tao which is the the model precision
and they actually estimated that using
Bayesian optimization but I just assumed
that was a fixed parameter from their
paper yeah a really interesting result
I was just wondering maybe relates to
the last question when you do this sort
of MC drop out can you give some guns on
the number of samples you need to get
some robust statistics or does that vary
quite lost it the the examples they give
they gave about 10,000 Forge passes
through the network so that obviously
slows things down yeah so that was the
training said at the stage is exactly
the same you have a train network that
takes the same but the test time is
scaled up by order T the amount of
stochastic forward passes you need to do
so they did 10,000 for these data sets
and I just basically run errands code
the great are cool the just out of sheer
pragmatic reasoning sometimes you could
still use PI mc3 sometimes you might
want to consider Edward is there any
advice on when you would use either
package because they seem to be doing
similar things at some point yes they do
I mean Edward has this a DVI which is
probably like you know next generation
black box variational inference that is
currently going into Edward at the
moment PI mc3 is also trying to put in
this normalizing flows for the work of
Ruiz ended in Shocker Mohammed so that
should also you know make better
variational approximations
I haven't actually benchmarked them and
that's actually the next thing I want to
do I won't actually run a load of
benchmarks for some of these other
systems a DVI etc yeah make them public
maybe it would be useful for that reason
hey over here
oh hello thanks for the great talk I was
wondering so if you compare this method
to so when we build an ensemble models
of multiple train your networks it's
kind of the same right although they're
all like maximum likelihood points but
we could have train an ensemble and then
run say a couple steps efficiency on
each of them and hopefully all of them
are like waving terror samples all from
a like they're not going to be suffering
from like being in the same mode as I
said were running just one chain of HMC
yeah would that work better like do you
expect that would like compare like so
both like without HMC at the end and
with a champion how would that okay yeah
I think there was a paper I references
1998 Barbour and Bishop where they use a
sort of ensemble approach if it's
difficult it's difficult to tell really
I don't know what the accuracy versus
the speed up trade off would be of using
variational inference the honest answer
it's something I'd like to try but I
don't know yet I mean generally the idea
would be variational inference will be a
little bit quicker that some of these
approaches but I don't know what the
accuracy trade-off is yeah okay quick
question so what if you train your let's
say to diagnose whether someone has
cancer from cat-scans you get let's say
95% classifier accuracy what's
preventing us from using that as the
confidence interval as a fixed
confidence and say like when I'm making
a prediction it's 95% accurate instead
of doing the Bayesian approach yeah yeah
you can I mean this is kind of like the
idea behind the Bayesian credible
interval you know a confidence interval
is like a frequentist analog of of
credible intervals so yeah I think it's
reasonable to use it in that kind of way
I think the credible intervals in
bayesian methods correspond quite well
to our intuition about well I'm
uncertain that how accurate my
measurement is so this thing gives me a
bands around it yeah I think you could
definitely use out in the principle
we have time for now was that Hertz in
there when you suck things together well
I mean you Altima tu looking at the
demands of theirs doesn't necessarily
matter you're putting your test set
through the network and you're getting
out a single prediction at the end with
drop-leg turned on you're doing this
lots and lots of times and then you're
beginning to get lots of why's you can
take the mean of those that would be the
mean of your predictive distribution and
you look at the standard deviation to
see how uncertain you are but without
this technique that you mention does you
turn on this initial way of doing it
which without the multiple passes oh
yeah so if you do without multiple
passes you can't really get the
uncertainty estimate so that's the way
that standard Drophead is actually used
it was described in this Avastin Hinton
papers weight averaging so they train
the network but when you do a single
pass through the network you kind of
basically assume the weights have been
averaged somehow so you can't get an
uncertainty interval because you're only
getting one prediction okay thank you
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]